it was the moment they'd been hoping for
[Applause]
Liverpool beating Glasgow to become next
year's Eurovision hosts
I love Eurovision and it's just to be in
my home City it's amazing
I can't describe how I feel I'm just
elated I've had this gut feeling all day
it is going like it's gonna be Liverpool
there was no way in my mind it was going
to be Glasgow sorry sorry but it was
going to be us and I'm just excited for
it to start when's it starting let's do
it now I can't wait yeah the contest
will head to the city in May and bring a
massive boost there's so many people who
will want to just experience the whole
Eurovision like feel and excitement and
it's definitely something that will come
to not only this part but to all the
bars in the area
um and it's just no we're so excited but
I know everyone else about it so excited
for as well so yeah it's gonna be
brilliant congratulations
so why Liverpool well the 2008 European
capital of culture has music built into
its very foundations you might not come
to Liverpool for the weather but you
would certainly stay for the music from
The Beatles to Cilla Black to 1993
Eurovision runner-up Sonia this is a
city with some serious musical clouds
and for some this win feels incredibly
poignant
Ukraine won the last competition but
because of the war can't host it so
Liverpool's success feels extra special
for the Ukrainian refugees who now call
the city home it's more than just the
Eurovision it's more just a song a song
is awesome
rise our mood it's also cheering us up
and cheering people up because when when
they stay in Ukraine they also like to
sing in hard moments in happy moments so
this like all music will all gather us
again together and shows that everything
is is fun will be even better
perhaps that's eurovision's enduring
appeal all that Glitter froth and fun
for some provides a moment of diversion
a moment of joy
liver Topsy Sky News in Liverpool